[موسيقى]
يصنف مؤشر السلام العالمي اليابان بين
الدول الاكثر امنا فمعدل السرقات فيها
خمسه عشره سرقه لكل مئه الف شخص اصلا
لدينا انطباعنا اليابان الياباني ذكي جدا
وليس بحاجه لان يسرق ثم من يجرؤ على
التفكير في السرقه في اليابان من يجرؤ
اصلا يخشى من ان موجات التكنولوجيا
الاشعاعيه الحديثه
ان ترصد افكاره فتصدر انذارا للشرطه لتاتي
وتعتقله لمجرد تفكير بخرق القانون لذلك
اصحاب محلات المجوهرات والساعات في شارع
جينزا بطوكيو مطمئنون
لكن هذا الذي حصل دخل اربعه من المقنعين
في وضح النهار الى محل ساعات مستعمله هذه
كسروا واجهات المحل
وهددوا عمال المحل بسكين كان يحملها احدهم
البقيه بداوا بجمع الساعات لما كل شيء
تقريبا صافي راس الانذار
ربما تسمعونها ضجه اسمها
الناس تتفرج مستغربين من الحادث في وضح
النهار كانت سيده ذهبت واغلقت وصورت هذه
المساله هناك من تبعهم طبعا وعثروا على
رقم السياره
على كل حال هذا هو المحل الذي تم سطو عليه
في وضح النهار محل بيع ساعات الفاخره
اغلبها رولكس في اهم شارع تجاريا في طوكيو
محروس يعني اما بالنسبه للرفوف التي تم
تنظيفها من قبل الحراميه
فكان عليها ساعات تبدا واسعارها من 3700
دولار الى 160 الف يعني قيمه كل المسروقات
التي سرقت اكثر من 700 الف دولار ساستعرض
لكم بعضا من تغريداتكم على حادثه السرقه
الطريفه في اليابان تقول لك منال مو
متعودين على الساطو لدرجه يحسبون جزء من
الفيلم عكس امريكا من كثر السطو اللي
عندهم لو يسوون فيلم يحاسبونه حقيقي او
سطو حقيقي عبد العزيز الشريف قال لك
الموضوع بحاجه للمزيد من الجديه في معاقبه
من يقوم بهذه الافعال خصوصا في لندن وايضا
بحاجه لقيام شركات الساعات بوضع لوائح
للارقام التسلسليه للساعات المسروقه لكي
يصعب على اللصوص بيعها صالح اليامي قال لك
صالح يا سلام حتى سرقاتهم تحسها حلوه لا
قتل ولا تهديد ولا مشاكل اشرق واهرب اما
بالنسبه لسعيد الغامدي فغلق سعيد بالقول
كذا عيني عينك وفي وسطه
الليل على الاقل الشارع يكون فاضي وما حد
يشوفكم والمحل فاضي برضه ما اعتقد بتطول
عمليه القاء القبض عليهم صحيح
لم تستغرق الشرطه الكثير لالقاء القبض
عليهم فالقت الشرطه القبض على اربعه اشخاص
اعمارهم بين 16 عاما وتسعه عشر عاما
مراهقين يعني والملاحظ حسب قول الشرطه ان
اللصوص لم يكونوا يعرفون بعضهم البعض
تجمعوا من اجل انهاء مهمه ما داهمت الشرطه
هذا المنزل لكن احد اللصوص رفض ان يسلم
نفسه ثم قامت الشرطه باقناعه قالت له اين
تريد ان تهرب يا حبيبي تعال تعال يا حبيبي
هيا بنا ناكل سوشي